Hello Freak bitches.
I,
I've used it a sign.
I found myself,
his him from time to time,
just for the fuck of it and hangs it.
Feel good.
Hangover,
hangover.
You feel like a vampire
vampire is looked like right?
They look at,
they're hung over like
when the sun comes out of
fucking,
what a weird idea is that sometimes
you can have vampires that fall all the
vampire rules until real recently
people got so fucking arrogant.
They were like,
well,
no,
no.
Now Vampires are actually your friend and
they only eat deer and they don't burn
when it's sunny out.
They just glisten and they
don't want to be glistening.
They sparkle Joe.
They don't listen.
They sparkle just vampires all of a sudden
became cool and you could fuck them.
Oh yeah dude.
Well that's Andrew Rice's fault.
Right?
And rise or phone.
Oh my God.
The fucking interview with a vampire.
No,
I don't think so man.
Because even before
interview with the Vampire,
Dracula was very sexual.
Dracula was a hypnotic.
Yeah,
he was a very sexual and like
a lot of the older movies,
you know,
there was a few of them.
The Gary Oldman.
What came first?
Gary Oldman or Anne Rice?
Probably in rice.
Right.
I don't want to Gary Oldman Dracula.
I think Anne Rice,
I'm always positive.
Actually.
I don't know the fucking Old Dracula,
I think the,
the Brahm Stoker Dracula.
Oh,
that was a long traps and the castle
didn't he have like there was a room you
went into and there are
all these female vampires.
Runyon hot.
Is that a call?
Yeah,
and like they were seductive
and they would like,
you know,
they were powerful Dracula.
That's the good point of what
everyone's hating on Dracula.
It's got these hard pitches
that want to suck blood.
They're ready to throw it out.
That's so funny.
Just gets a bone him.
He never bound them in
front of you buddy though.
It was just,
I guess once you start drinking people's
blood that's like way cooler than
bowling and checks.
He just completely give up on bowling.
I mean in the world of vampires,
it's that is boning the best
track live though of all time?
Unquestionably.
It was Gary Oldman.
Did you see that one?
I don't.
Bram stoker I sold.
It's so good that Kiana
Reeves can't fuck it up.
I got it like I don't know
cause I haven't seen it,
but I'll tell you my favorite fucking
vampire or the way I do like Keanu Reeves.
It's just as cheap joke.
I like calories.
It's true.
I love you can't,
Oh God,
I love you didn't pay
attention to my joke.
You just waiting to see
what you going to say.
I'll tell you why.
Here's where my mind started wandering
is you said the greatest vampire and then
I thought,
no,
no.
The greatest vampire of all time.
The spookiest vampire about time.
It's fucking Nosferatu.
Oh,
the original.
Yeah,
you're right.
Fuck that thing.
We'll also,
that was like really original.
I mean,
and think about that guy did that.
It was like,
what else is a silent movie now?
Man,
that thing was a scary son of a bitch,
whatever.
That was like,
that's what a vampires like
the long fingers kind of
Goblin fucking creepy thing
pops out of the shadows.
That onsite dude,
keep talking.
I love it.
Sorry my,
my yapping too much.
Oh,
I love it.
you do?
Really?
Yeah,
man.
Last fed out to.
Yeah,
man,
that guy is fucking scary.
But you know,
the Salem's lot vampires are pretty
fucking spooky to 1922 brother,
1922 and I'm looking at
the images of it right now.
Oh my God.
It's fucking incredible.
Yeah.
It was legitimately frightening.
Legitimately frightening.
And it was in the fucking
early 19 hundreds dude.
Rentable.
And they find fucking coffin still too.
You know,
they found coffins out there are people
have hammered stakes into the Oh yeah.
Well there's probably,
I'm sure people that were fucking
assholes and they just wanted to make sure
that it really never came back.
But this motherfucker was creepy.
You're right,
man.
You know,
he might be the scariest whenever.
Yeah.
Especially when you consider
it was 90 fucking years ago.
Yeah.
Man,
that was fucking spit.
Well,
I mean now it's based on the real thing.
Whatever is wandering around out
in the fucking woods of Germany.
That's what was out there.
What a crazy people.
Do you remember?
Uh,
it was,
uh,
it was based on a real man.
The,
Oh my God,
look,
there's fucking photo of it,
dude.
It's a really good goddamn image.
I didn't really fucking scary looking.
Yeah,
that's a scary vampire.
1922,
because if you go watch like King Kong,
King Kong is not really scary.
And that's a little from like the 30s.
Nope.
Not Scary at all.
And it's scary.
It can con can not fuck with Nosferatu.
No,
not,
I mean,
I guess if I had to pick
who I wanted to run from,
it's going to be a
fucking Nosferatu though.
But I weird.
Is it that they just hijacked
the whole vampire thing?
Vampires used to be the worst shit that
could ever happen to and now he's a
hunky guy.
Well,
I'll tell you why they
fucking did that shit,
bro in it.
Yeah.
You got to sell it to teenagers.
It's women,
men,
lot of women.
Well,
people that want the want romance,
right?
The,
uh,
the thing about the twilight books,
so I've been told by Mrs Rogan,
uh,
is that the very romantic,
unrealistically romantic because he's a
vampire and it's like he's got all the
super power and everything like that.
It's like he,
like he's giving it all up,
but just to be with her,
you know what I mean?
And it's this weird sort of like,
he,
he needs her so much and
women love that shit.
It's just a natural sort
of a thing for though.
So like when you see women that would be
waiting in line to go to those movies,
that just,
it just hits a chord that we don't,
we don't have,
we don't know that court,
but the Chica wrote that
shit knows their cord.
So she nailed it.
She talking about the quarter love,
I'm talking about the court
of affection and admiration.
Like I think all women want to be,
you know,
the w don't want to be worshiped,
they think that that's like the most
romantic thing for a guy who would do
anything for you.
So he would do anything for that girl in,
in,
in those books.
He would do anything for,
I mean he,
he didn't even want to bite her.
He wanted to,
he wanted to protect her from
everybody who was in love with her.
Meanwhile,
he was like a thousand years
old and she's in high school.
Like it's really fucking creepy
if you stop and think about it.
He's a thousand years old
or whatever the fuck it is.
I tell them she's in high school,
man,
you are.
You're fucking crazy kind of
conversations you're having with her.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
it'd be hard enough if you were 30 you
were 30 and you're dating a girl in high
school,
you'd be like,
I got to kill myself.
I can't take it.
I can't talk to her.
She's fucking just shows.
All she wants to talk about is
Instagram thousand year old per se.
Fucking creeper ups.
He's a total creeper.
She could be as great Greg.
It's not like he just was
frozen for all those years.
Like captain America.
No,
this asshole's been alive the whole time
and pretend that he's in high school.
It might be one of the dumbest ideas ever.
It's not fair.
He's got magical powers.
He can fly.
He's flying a fucking high
school kid through the trees.
Jesus Christ.
Did they fuck?
Yes.
Eventually.
Yeah.
Later in the boiler spoiler.
Yes.
Allegedly.
How about that?
I Dunno.
It was.
It already happened.
It might have already happened.
I only saw like two of them.
I think there's been three of them.
Put it in her asshole.
I don't think they had
partial lot to do that.
It's a sin even for vampires.
Vampires.
No,
no,
no.
Females.
That project,
we'll cut the shape.
Just stop it.
They don't even shit anymore,
so it probably drives up nice,
don't shit.
When you're eating blood,
they probably barely have to urinate.
You probably get the
exact amount you need.
You don't know that.
I would imagine you would get
the exact amount you need now,
man of vampires.
Asshole is swollen.
Brogan.
A scene where you walked down into a New
York City subway and you saw some crazy
looking vampire dude.
You shitting blood,
which is blood squirting out of
his chunky cottage cheese blood.
That's what a vampire looks like.
Tunnel,
subway tunnel,
just shitting blood,
looking at you and thinking
about sucking your blood next.
It's weird like that's that.
That's as far as they go.
Like vampires suck your blood.
That's the worst thing they do,
but there's never been like a supernatural
creature that won't be like mouth
fucks you.
You know what I mean?
Some,
we talked about that before.
As ridiculous as it is.
I think we actually did
talk about this before.
It must be on my fucking mind,
man.
There's no fucking bat or
some creepy for rapes people.
There was mouth rape and dudes,
I don't use that word,
but it they're a fucking arm.
Horrifying,
horrifying being.
It doesn't have to be a vampire.
He could just be some bug,
some insect or something that came out
of the earth and that's how it does it.
It just fucking,
it made her,
it leaves off of the,
it lives off of like people gagging.
It absorbs the
gagging.
It gets power for the trick.
The twitching of your body when you're
trying to throw up gag pyre pipe is
clogged by fat cock.
You can't even throw up.
You're trying to throw up and he's just
holding the back of your head with Scaly
Paul.
That's what they came to do.
They just came to get head.
They have a really tough dicks.
Like you really cannot
even pierce the skin.
You can bite it as hard as you want.
It doesn't matter when
alien's face fuck you.
They just did.
It just goes in.
You accept it and it,
it just fucks your throat
when you try to throw up.
But he can't get past the fat alien
cock that's stretching your insides out,
pumping oxygen.
And by the way,
it's keeping you alive in you alive.
Why you suck at Scott's.
It changes your whole,
it blows your lungs out and
actually eats them and uh,
converts it to a type of glue that keeps
the cock attached to your body to keep
you alive.
Cause now you no longer have lungs.
You get all your oxygen through his cock.
Oh my God.
Could you imagine?
That would be the word.
And in some people would say,
you know what,
I don't care.
I love aliens anyway.
There's still awesome her teaching us.
Listen,
if for him might be really awesome,
maybe he loves the fact that he's
getting the oxygen to that cock.
You stay alive.
Your body where there's a
way you can't really move.
Your arms are flailing
and you like him paled,
you just look like a skeleton with a
fucking Dildo in its mouth and every year
it just goes deeper in your body,
keeps that keeps growing.
Eventually it turns into you,
you just turn it in like a
cactus like cactus Dick thing.
If you look at Sugar Bob Shish Kebab,
Dick Kebab every year the the,
the,
the Dick slowly grows inside your
body and starts cracking open.
Oregon's and pushing ribs to this side,
popping and snapping them as it
eventually goes through your body.
But it does it so slowly
that you never actually die,
especially since the,
uh,
the deck is providing with oxygen,
but then when it gets to the hat,
to the end,
the deck pops out of your asshole
and you deflate like a balloon.
And that,
and that sound is that
sound is known as funking.
Like it's like the sound
of a man's final farm.
There's no words sound.
It's like a pinky.
Okay.